Speaker 1: Let's go to the phones. By which I mean
Discord and hear from some of those very important
people, the people in the audience. You can find
our discord at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
Always use proper show calling etiquette.
You get right to your question. You have
good audio and all of these different
things. It's going to be a beautiful,
beautiful day of calls. I am sure I can just
feel it. Let's go today, starting with Lucas from
Massachusetts. Lucas from Massachusetts, welcome.
You're our first caller. Let's hope for the best.
Speaker 5: Hey, David. Hi. So now can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can't. Are you in a in a in
an echoey? Where are you in some
kind of Turkish bath or something?
Speaker 5: Of my door. Of my.
Speaker 4: Dormitory. Oh,
you're in the hotels here.
Speaker 1: Beautiful. What's going on?
Speaker 5: So this is a loaded question.
But not long ago, I watched a Thom Hartmann
segment in which he asked the question if Trump's
handling of COVID should be labeled a genocide.
And they said, What your thoughts are on that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I got a similar question recently
about something related to trans and genocide.
I you know, I don't find it super compelling to
weigh in on that because the truth is you can make
these linguistic arguments one way or another,
that the reality is that Trump handled COVID
terribly and more people died than would have
if he had handled that better. But I don't know
that any country handled that perfectly. And
I think in every country some people died that
that could have lived had it been handled better.
We had limited information, etc.. Trump was
particularly bad. So which is the genocide that
anyone died that didn't have to or that more than
in other countries? It's tough. It's really tough.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I guess because Trump
there's evidence that he hired more
people in those days had die beginning.
Speaker 1: I'm sorry. You're saying it
is what Trump do because.
Speaker 5: He wanted more
people from Blue State to die?
Isn't he on recording saying
that? I might be remembering wrong, but.
Speaker 1: I'm not aware that it was that
he wanted people from blue states to die. But he
ignorantly saw that the early infections were in
blue states because that's where a lot of the big
airports are. And he wrongly thought it wouldn't
come to red states. How wrong he was, though.
Speaker 5: It was very wrong. Yeah. Anyway,
that's the only question I had. Thank
you. And you have to see this on the show.
Speaker 1: All right. Lucas from Massachusetts,
thank you so much for the call. Appreciate it